[Music]
hey Bill Nye its tailor baggert I was
wondering what you think about the
censorship of scientific discoveries if
the discovery could be used in a harmful
way if there were censorship how should
the censorship process be designed and
what groups should be involved in
determining what the public does and
does not get to know thanks so much
Taylor Taylor Taylor we in the
scientific community have this process
we have this censorship process in the
sense that we have what's called peer
review this is where somebody comes up
with a scientific claim or a belief or a
test result experimental result other
people read it read the paper study his
or her results and see if there's any
validity to them then if there is that
paper or that information gets published
so there is in a sense scientific
censorship in a sense if someone makes
an extraordinary claim that silly or can
provably wrong there are systems in
place to point out that this thing is
not true and ignore it it didn't work
it's not relevant
however we are living in a time when
there's virtually no censorship
everything ends up in the World Wide Web
information is available to everybody so
the real challenge is not censorship
it's what I would call critical thinking
or self-censorship where you need the
ability we all need the ability to read
all this information or be exposed to
all this information and decide whether
or not it's true as we record this right
now late in the year 2016 there's a
spate or a fad or a trend of news
sources which aren't real these are a
false news that we hear big think like
to think you know we're super weel this
is it this is the place to tune in but
there's a big trend right now to create
false news things that look like real
news that aren't the journalistic
traditions which are consistent with the
peer review process in science
or being overwhelmed or overrun by the
ability of anyone to put anything he or
she wants on the electric internet so it
is up to you tailor to learn to sort
this stuff out
now along this line if you're talking
about secrecy secrecy is a big deal in
the military you know I you know I had
security clearance very briefly and you
take it you just take it really
seriously because you think the security
of your native country is at stake and
along this line the real places you need
security are now are not are no longer
really satellite photos and the top
speed of certain aircraft or or how long
a submarine can remain submerged as
those aren't the secrets that are
concerning us now it's what's on the
Internet what information is stored
electronically for all sort of the
Department of Defense or the European
Space Agency or what have you that's the
information that needs to be secured now
and I when you say sensor I heard you
referred to who's going to adjudicator
who's gonna be at the top who's gonna
make the decisions and those traditions
of secrecy I think will be in the
military anyway will be there for a long
time but the real problem is the lack of
censorship it's just stuff all this
information is everywhere so we need to
find ways to sort it out because there's
there's no stopping it once when you try
to retract something that's been
published electronically it's very
different it's very difficult what we
need is people to notice that whatever
was clearly false that was published was
clearly false that is a great question
and it's one for your generation Taylor
use your critical thinking skills
evaluate evidence don't believe
everything you read or see on the other
hand there are some things that you can
read that are true atomic number of
rubidium is one of my favorites it's 37
you can look it up thank you
[Music]